I have an apology I need to make an
apology to jujitsu people everywhere
when I said that smaller dudes are
always at a disadvantage against big
dudes like that some of the jujitsu
people sent me I sent you that video of
that one I don't know why you argued me
on this stuff it's like me arguing
politics feel like what to me is that
strong but bubbling I don't know I
whatever you've studied I've been
engulfed in that world for years I just
thought you were being like politically
correct if you will
no you know what I mean I thought you
were done being a little bit like no not
at all yeah I have no reason to offend
you Jitsu yeah I don't know why you
argue with me I'm people were sending me
[ __ ] of like giant black belts who were
competitive against like world class go
that guy that Eddie Bravo 10th planet
guy who was part of a freak brother calm
this [ __ ] I was just like oh my god
me I that I but I've lived that dude so
when you argue me I'm like [ __ ] yeah
you've lived it I don't know why you
argue I'm a guy I don't yeah I know you
did like two years at handles well can I
be honest with you a lot of us because
I've seen you take world class guys who
are smaller and completely neutralized
you haven't but you've also seen me you
you you've lost again here nod you're
also been that's after you've been
training for 10 for 8 years I was a
professional athlete though yeah your
lot just doesn't make sense right and
wrestler and you've been doing it that
long yeah so it's different instead but
also you've also seen been in there when
the hunter and he run roll me the [ __ ]
up yes I'm way bigger than those guys
yes way big yes that is you were there
when they [ __ ] me and Leo machito up
in the same room that is correct
don't you remember and you'll remember
it very well and in fact Henner started
on his back I talked to him and
destroyed when I went that's my you
slimness I was like oh you're ahead of
them he's heady but but he's also six
five and long and tall so much lighter
than me yes I am I 60 pounds at least
yeah that's 180 pounds that's not a good
example though cuz he's he's big enough
to be beat anybody I mean he's long and
he's he's still hot ready now yeah your
argument a smaller guy a bigger guy
could neutralize that well I mean then
like you said with T City who would you
say would just wrap up you know so many
people who were huge huge again but
I've seen it I'm here as live that life
seems any argument it's almost I'm just
like ah I don't know I just was like
[ __ ] I I again it's because I got I
saw you and your strength and just
taking guys who here's the problem with
that you're assuming because I'm
stronger I'm beating them no you're
something course you're I did you see
yeah ten years yeah UFC yeah every so
you're taking that yeah and saying oh no
big guys can neutralize jujitsu death
it's had T cities girl you're gonna a
date with her I don't know but she's
been the most desired girl in a while
who is she
Valerie Loretta she fights for belt on
super body though god bless I see her
pictures yeah I do
I certainly do buddy is here playing
with little puppy oh well she's she's
the hottest girl in MMA without a doubt
there's heard probably dancing it's got
a yeah I mean if you're into that if
you're in a small waist in perfect
fascism it's ridiculous and she fights
yeah high level fighter yeah yeah man
she is a measure one of her friends
what's going on what is going on
general I'm saying though what's going
on God the comet why are you outside
[ __ ] I hate [ __ ] I mean she's uh
she's just a straight-up dimepiece who
decide to get a punch in the face for a
living well I can't have her getting
punched in the face I will save her
right now what are your bills girl is
that is that Mazda yeah
easy with the rumors easy
I'm not saturating the training partners
that's that's training partner okay god
she's right
John with you I'll show you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]